foreign
[Music]
to another by modifying either the
source or destination address
information in the IP header
IPS grading is a form of nat that is
typically used to perform many to one
address translation via multiple Source
IP addresses are masked behind a single
IP address
this helps improve security and
decreases the number of IB addresses
your organization needs
in this video you will learn how
ipmashgrading Works in Google kubernetes
engine what components are involved in
configuring it how to configure it in a
gke standard cluster and finally how to
troubleshoot and resolve a common issue
with ipmask grading let's get started
inside a GK cluster pods usually have
private IP addresses from RSC 1918
ranges which are not routable on the
public internet so when a pod sends
Network traffic to a destination on the
public internet IPS grading is used to
change the source IP address of packets
sent from the part to the underlying
notes IP address this is also useful
when a recipient is configured to
receive packets only from the Clusters
node IP addresses
on Linux nodes GK configures iptable
rules to perform IP mask reading GK uses
the ipmask agent which runs as a demon
set in your cluster to configure the
appropriate data plane the ipmask agent
configures iptable rules in a node to
handle the mask reading of pod IP
addresses when sending traffic to other
nodes or destinations outside the
cluster this essentially hides pod IP
addresses behind the cluster node's IP
address
this will be helpful especially in
scenario where it is expected that
traffic to external addresses must come
from known machine addresses the two
main components involved in configuring
IP mask reading in gke are the ipmask
agent demon set which is responsible for
configuring the necessary iptable rules
to perform Source address translation in
the Linux kernel and uses the ipmask
agent config map the ipmask agent config
map enables you to specify a range of
destination IP addresses for which the
Parts Source IP address is preserved
when packets are sent out
alright let's take a look at the steps
involved in configuring ipmask grading
NGK Step 1 check if the IP mask agent
demands it and config map are present in
your cluster if not use the below link
to create these resources
Step 2 create and update the ipmask
agent config map
here is a sample ipmask agent config map
for reference by default every outbound
connection undergoes IP mask reading
except the default non-masquerade cidrs
for example if you want to preserve a
pod's IP address then you must Define a
list of destination IB addresses in cidr
format under the non-masquerade cidr
option
when packets are sent to these
destinations your cluster does not
masquerade The Source IP address and
thereby press of pod IP addresses all
other destinations that are not part of
non-masquerade cidrs list undergo Source
address translation let's dive into a
demo and learn how to troubleshoot and
resolve a common issue that can be seen
if IP mask reading is not configured
correctly
consider the following scenario a client
part running inside a GK cluster with
connectivity to on-prem using Cloud VPN
there is an application running on
on-prem with the IP address
10.151.0.2 which needs to be accessed
from the client part the on-prem
application is configured such that it
accepts connections only from the
powered IP addresses
let's now make an HTTP request from the
client to the on-prem application
oops it's not working
this is because the pods IP address is
mass graded behind the node's IP address
to fix this issue you must disable
ipmask reading of powered IP address
when the destination is on-prem
application
check if the IP mask agent is running
inside the cluster by running the
following command
this indicates the ipmask agent is
running inside the cluster as a demon
said
check the IP mask kitchen config map
from the GK console
select the option secrets and config map
unselect the option is system object
false
search for IP mask agent resources
select it
click on the edit button
under the non-masquerade cidr block add
the Range
10.151.0.2 32 to prevent IP Mass grading
for any traffic going to the on-prem
application
save the changes
let's try make the HTTP request from the
client to the on-prem
success the connectivity between the Pod
and the on-prem application is now
working successfully
for more details about ibmask rating in
gke check out the following documents
thanks for watching the video
[Music]